come sarebbe il mondo senza La retorica
La retorica gode di pessima fame Eppure
una delle più sofisticate tecnologie
della mente e meriterebbe di tornare in
modo attivo nelle scuole nelle
università e nei centri di formazione
italiani si dice parlo senza retorica
per dire parlo in modo schietto in modo
onesto senza infingimenti e si dice che
si usa la retorica Quando non si ha
niente da dire quando si vuole gonfiare
il discorso o addirittura quando si
vuole imbrogliare qualcuno ma come
sarebbe il mondo senza La retorica
Secondo alcuni Sarebbe migliore Tutto
chiaro tutto onesto tutto schietto
niente orpelli niente svolazzi pane al
pane vino al vino Ma questa è già una
figura retorica Facciamo un esperimento
costruiamo un vocabolario
retorica normale normale retorica il
gioco è molto semplice prendiamo delle
espressioni tipicamente retoriche e le
traduciamo in normalese Cioè in
espressioni Piane semplici quelle che
chiamano espressioni oneste e vediamo
l'effetto che fa e facciamo questo
esperimento con i grandi discorsi del
passato e del della storia contemporanea
e del presente
è il discorso per antonomasia proprio il
discorso dei discorsi quando pensi Pensi
a un discorso pensi a questo discorso
qui è un sogno di Martin Luther King
siamo a Washington è il 1963 e
tantissime persone sono accorse a
Washington per ascoltare le parole del
reverendo King e
ci sono persone bianche ci sono persone
nere che sono venute ad ascoltare le
parole di Martin Luther King e lui in
questo contesto Parla Senza retorica e
dice Io ho un progetto ho un progetto di
uguaglianza tra i cittadini italiani i
cittadini americani di origine europea e
cittadini americani di origine africana
e di tutte le altre origini di questa è
la versione sterilizzata normalizzata
del discorso di Martin Luther King senza
retorica però le sue parole diventano
iconiche quel giorno perché lui non lo
dice così lui lo dice in un modo che noi
tutti ricordiamo perché lui quel giorno
in quella spianata Washington dice Io ho
un sogno che un giorno sulle rosse
Colline della Georgia i figli di coloro
che furono schiavi e i figli di coloro
che possedettero gli schiavi sapranno
sedere insieme al tavolo della
Fratellanza
una metafora il sogno una seconda
metafora il tavolo due metafore
tantissime metafore per rendere il mondo
più giusto e più umano attraverso la
forza della parola questo è Martin
Luther King Però forse l'esempio
sbagliato quindi prendiamo un altro
esempio un esempio in italiano di un
famosissimo discorso italiano quando
pensiamo al discorso italiano per
antonomasia pensiamo al discorso della
Luna di Giovanni XXIII è il 1962 Siamo a
San Pietro la piazza è stra piena di
gente ci sono i fedeli hanno delle
fiaccole in mano e la notte che è una
notte di ottobre è rischiarata dalla
Luna tanto che questo prende nome
proprio dalla Luna del discorso della
Luna di Giovanni XXIII e quello che dice
Giovanni XXIII è il papa è talmente
forte e talmente vero ed è talmente
giusto che non mi serve il doping della
retorica perché la verità emerge nel suo
splendore E infatti lui senza retorica
avrebbe potuto dire così dovete amare i
vostri figli e dovete dire ai vostri
figli che anche il papa li ama e vuole
loro bene Questa è la versione così
semplice senza retorica Però
effettivamente è un po' freddina e poi
non sarebbero rimaste parole iconiche
per sempre queste qui infatti il papa
quel giorno noi tutti ricordiamo che
dice che lo dice in un altro modo dice
tornando a casa
date una carezza ai vostri bambini e
dite Questa è la carezza del Papa
una sineddoche una piccola sineddoche ma
una magnifica sineddoche la parte per il
tutto questa è L'asinello che la parte è
La carezza il tutto è quella stanza
quella sined che mi porta per mano in
quella stanza io entro in quella stanza
e lo vedo quel bambino che dorme
lo sento ascolto sul respiro e sento
l'odore di quella stanza e vedo le
ciglia del bambino appoggiate sulla sua
guancia Questa è la forza della retorica
sto là dentro perché la retorica parla
agli occhi più che alle orecchie e il
linguaggio diventa cinema
un altro esempio veniamo ai nostri
giorni prendiamo una ragazzina una
ragazzina che va all'onu nel 2019 e
pronuncia un discorso dove lei è
veramente molto molto molto molto
arrabbiata si chiama Greta thunberg e ce
l'ha con i potenti della terra perché
quando la vedono dico Brava brava Greta
bravissima è giusto quello che dici Bene
bene però poi vanno nella stanza dei
bottoni e prendono decisioni
completamente diverse e lei è arrabbiata
talmente arrabbiata e che diventa tutta
rossa e la voce è rotta dalle emozioni
sta quasi per piangere quando parla però
forse avrebbe potuto dire queste cose
con più pacatezza con più semplicità
perché tutta questa emozione a volte può
disturbare e con semplicità senza
retorica avrebbe potuto dire dovete fare
qualcosa per fermare i cambiamenti
climatici
Però lei non lo dice così perché lei
vuole far capire al mondo che è
arrabbiata a questo mondo dei potenti
che la prende in giro che le dice sì tu
hai ragione Però poi di fatto fanno cose
completamente diverse quando devono
veramente decidere e infatti lei quel
giorno l'ONU nel 2019 dice il mio
messaggio
è che vi terremo d'occhio
io non dovrei essere qui io dovrei
essere a scuola dall'altra parte
dell'oceano
Venite dai noi giovani a cercare
speranza come osate avete rubato i miei
sogni e la mia infanzia con le vostre
parole vuote
Questa è la strategia retorica
dell'invettiva è quella strategia che ti
fa mordere la realtà attraverso le
parole che ti fa infilare il dito nella
piaga attraverso le parole Poi quando
infili quel dito in quella piaga tu lo
giri quel dito perché stai usando quella
strategia dell'invettiva perché devi
essere incisivo in quel momento e a
volte hai bisogno della chiarezza della
retorica
come questa giacca
La retorica può farti brillare
La retorica fa fare boom ai tuoi
discorsi le figure retoriche sono i
tuoni nella notte sono quelle
espressioni che si fissano nella testa
del roditore lo fanno sobbalzare lo
fanno uscire dal torpore
Ma attenzione però perché come questa
giacca La retorica può farti brillare
può offuscare la tua vista e può rendere
luminoso ciò che oscuro positivo ciò che
è negativo
1938 Trieste Mussolini sta su un balcone
Pronuncia un discorso che spalanca le
porte alle leggi razziste
l'ebraismo mondiale
in questi 16 anni e malgrado le nostre
politiche è stato un nemico
irreconciliabile della razza
Chi conosce le strategie della retorica
sta bene che Mussolini in questo momento
sta usando la strategia del nemico la
strategia del nemico mi permette di
porre davanti al popolo Un nemico da
odiare per distrarlo dai problemi di
tutti i giorni è una strategia di
distrazione di Massa
usiamo e conosciamo La retorica
usiamo La retorica perché la retorica fa
volare i nostri pensieri proprio come
Martin Luther King anche se noi non
siamo Martin Luther King anche nel
nostro piccolo Noi possiamo fare la
differenza attraverso la forza delle
parole anche a scuola nel nostro circolo
di amicizie sul lavoro anche al circolo
del tennis
conosciamo La retorica perché se noi
conosciamo La retorica ci vacciniamo
dalla manipolazione e dalle parole
dell'odio
e ricordiamo che i dittatori di ieri ma
anche quelli di oggi sono stati Amati
sono stati rispettati e sono stati anche
ampiamente votati anche grazie alla loro
capacità retorica
facciamo tornare La retorica nelle
scuole nelle università e nei centri di
formazione italiane perché perché
la retorica ci aiuta a parlare La
retorica ci aiuta a comprendere e la
retorica ci aiuta a decidere Viva La
retorica
[Applauso]